The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Let us get started.
The first thing we're
going to do today
is I'm going to finish up
what I didn't get a chance
to finish the last time, because
we ran over a little bit.
And what we are going
to cover to begin with
is the lateral geniculate
nucleus of the thalamus.
This is a structure
in the thalamus that
receives an extensive
input from the retina
from retinal ganglion cells.
And it is a beautiful structure
that has several layers to it.
And here is a picture
of one from a monkey.
And this is a coronal section.
I think you all
know a little bit
about the anatomy of the brain.
If you cut slices this
way, it's coronal cuts.
If you cut it this way,
it's sagittal cuts.
OK?
So this is a coronal cut.
A thin slice.
And it shows what the
lateral geniculate nucleus
looks like when it's
cut about in its middle.
And what you can say is
a bunch of layers here.
There's six layers
as labeled here.
And the top four layers are
called the parvocellular
layers.
And the bottom two are called
the magnocellular layers.
And the reason they
have these names
is because the cells--
this was stained.
You can't see it that clearly.
But the cells are much bigger
in the bottom two layers
than in the top four layers.
And that's why these
are called parvo,
and these are called magno.
Now, one of the important
discoveries that had been made,
and I'll belabor
that in a minute,
is that these top
four layers get input
from the midget
cells of the retina,
and the bottom two get input
from the parasol cells.
And we'll be talking about that
a great deal in the next few
lectures.
Now, each of these layers
gets input from one eye.
And there's an alternation.
If you go from
layer six, this is
input for a contralateral line.
Ipsilateral.
Contralateral.
Then there is a reversal.
And this layer is
again ipsilateral.
And this layer is contralateral.
So that is the basic layout.
And I might as well
anticipate to tell you
that if you study
the receptive field
organization of these cells,
they are very similar to those
that you see in the retina.
You have midget cells.
Parasol cells.
You have center-surround
antagonism.
So that there is not
much of a transform
at this level in the brain,
as the inputs progress
from the retina to the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
But once we get
up to the cortex,
we will see many
major transforms
that I will come to shortly.
Now, the layout of the
lateral geniculate nucleus
varies quite a bit from
species to species.
In the market we have
this kind of arrangement.
And this is very similar
to the kind of arrangement
we have in our own heads.
But then if you look at-- well,
let me make one more point here
about this.
There's a beautiful
experiment that's
been done to confirm that
indeed the inputs to the parvo
and magnocellular
layers are coming
from different
cells in the retina.
And so an experiment was done
in which a labeling material was
put into either
the parvocellular
layers or the
magnocellular layers,
as you can see here
on the right side.
Then those labeling substances
were transported back
to the retina.
And they labeled the cells
that project to the axons
into these two regions.
And what you can see
here is that these
are smaller cells that project
to the parvocellular layers,
and much bigger cells that
project to the magnocellular
layers.
And these correspond,
as other studies
have shown in more detail,
to the parasol cells.
And these correspond
to the midget cells.
So that's an important
distinction here of the inputs.
And the other thing that's
important to realize here
is that we talked about
how the eye is organizing,
and the way it projects
to the nasal and temple
parts of the retina.
The left lateral
geniculate nucleus
sees the right half
of the visual field,
and right geniculate sees the
left half of the visual field.
Now, let me say just a
few words about the fact
that there are different
kinds of geniculates.
But they're not that different.
So here's an example
of a tree shrew
lateral geniculate nucleus.
It's shaped differently,
but it still
has these nice six layers.
And the bottom two layers
again are magnocellular,
and the top four layers are
essentially parvocellular.
But then when
recordings were made,
an interesting
specialization was
seen in this animal, which was
not that obvious in others.
If you look at this here,
examine the question
to what degree are the cells
in these top four layers
on or off cells.
And what you see here, that
when you look at layers three,
four, five, and six, there's
a huge distinction here.
Virtually all the cells in
three and four are off cells,
and all the cells in five
and six are on cells.
So there's a specialization
in the layers
as to whether the input is
from the on cells or off cells.
And yet another animal has a
different kind of arrangement.
I'm not going to go into
more details about this,
but again there's
six layers here.
But here they don't seem to
have a distinction between magno
and parvocellular layers.
Instead we have two
layers, five and four,
where the cells are very small.
And the rest of the
layers are quite large.
This is the galago.
All right?
Now most thoroughly studied had
been the cat, and the monkey.
And that's the kind
of stuff we are
going to talk about more as
we progress in the course.
All right.
So that in a very summary
form is the essence
of what that lateral
geniculate nucleus is like.
Now, what I want
to do is I'm going
to have a quick
summary of what I've
covered in the first session.
And here, first of all
again, is a drawing
of what the cells look
like in the retina.
These are the photoreceptors.
Remember the light is coming
in from the bottom up.
OK?
And so if you look
at that, we find
that all the photoreceptors
hyperpolarize the light,
and they produce only
graded potentials.
My last important fact
is that all these cells
use glutamate as the
neurotransmitter that
is released at the bottom here
of these cells, which then
innervates the
subsequent elements
in this retinal
picture here, which
are the horizontal cells
and the bipolar cells.
So if you look at those,
the horizontal cells
are all hyperpolarized to light
just to the photoreceptors.
And they also only
produce graded potentials.
But then when we proceed, and
look at the bipolar cells,
there are two major
classes of bipolar cells
that I want to deal
with, and more.
These are the important
ones from our point of view.
The so-called on
and off bipolars.
And that arises,
because the on bipolars
have signed inverting
synapses with which they
connect to the photoreceptors.
Whereas the off bipolars have
signed conserving synapses.
So the way to think of
this, if the photoreceptor
hyperpolarizes and depolarizes,
going up and down as the light
goes in and out,
an off cell will
mimic this, and go like this.
But the on cell will
do the opposite.
OK?
So we have created in the
retina, I shouldn't say we,
but evolution has, from
a single-ended system
since they were hyperpolarized,
a double-ended system
at the level of
the bipolar cell.
And that's what then creates
these famous on and off cells
that we are going to
talk about in a lot
more detail the next
time to try to figure out
why do we have these cells.
All right.
So that then is a summary
of the upper layers.
And then when they come
down to the amacrine cells,
some of these amacrine cells
produce action potentials.
Some don't.
There are many different kinds,
as I mentioned the last time.
There are more than
20 different kinds.
Some are on.
Some are off.
Some are on-off.
And some don't even give
you action potentials.
Then finally when you come
down to the ganglion cells,
they all give you
action potentials.
And the major two
classes that we
are going to deal with a lot,
even though there are many
more, we'll talk about
some of them later,
are the midget cells
and the parasol cells.
OK.
So then to have an overall
summary of what we covered
the last time, first of
all, we had the right brain
receives input from the
left visual hemifield,
and the left from
the right hemifield.
That, you understood
when I explained to you
what the wiring is
like in the retina.
And then I pointed
out, just seeing
that, we have these five major
classes of retinal cells.
We have the
photoreceptors themselves,
which are the rods
and the cords.
And then we have the horizontal
cells, the bipolar cells,
the amacrine cells, and
the retinal ganglion cells.
Hopefully, by
repeating this stuff,
eventually this will
stick into your brain.
All right.
So then the receptive fields,
or the retinal ganglion
cells, sometimes
referred to as RGCs,
have antagonistic centers
around organization.
And then when we look at
the question of adaptation,
you can explain why on
earth did this evolve.
This complex arrangement.
Then there are several classes
of retinal ganglion cells.
We have talked about the on and
off, the midget and parasol,
and we will later on talk
about several other classes.
Now, all photoreceptors
and horizontal cells
hyperpolarize the light.
At that level you have
a single-ended system.
But then when you come to
the bipolar cells, about half
of them are hyperpolarizing, and
half of them are depolarizing.
And the opposition arises,
because the on bipolar cells
have an inverting
synapse, which is
due to their
intersynaptic junction
where their receptors
are made of molecules,
which is called the mGluR6.
And we'll talk about that
in more detail next time.
The action potentials
in the retina
are generated by only amacrine
cells and retinal ganglion
cells.
The lateral geniculate nucleus
that we have talked about
is a laminated structure,
but desegregating lamina
varies with species just
as I pointed out to you.
The parvocellular layers receive
input from the midget cells,
and the magnocellular layers
from the parasol cells
in the monkey, and in the human.
OK?
The inputs in the left and right
are segregated into lamina,
as I have already
pointed out to you.
Lastly, the receptive
few properties
of lateral geniculate
cells are similar to those
that you see in the
retina ganglion cells.
You don't have any
major transforms.
OK.
So that's then what we have an
initial understanding of when
it comes to the retina, and
the lateral geniculate nucleus.
We are now going to proceed,
hang on for a minute,
to the visual cortex.
All right.
So we are going to talk
about the visual cortex.
OK.
So the first thing we are going
to talk about that pertains
to the visual cortex is
V1, this initial area
that gets most of
the input directly
from the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
And we're going to
look at this first
from an anatomical
point of view.
And then we're going to look
at it progressively more
from a functional point of view.
OK.
So here once again
is a monkey brain.
You're going to see this monkey
brain over and over again,
and gradually will
become familiar with it.
I want to point out to you that
this here is a central sulcus.
Just like we have a central
sulcus, so do monkeys.
And then this area here is
called the lunate sulcus.
And then in front
here, we are going
to talk about this region.
It's called the
frontal eye fields.
There are two.
The soft side, the
principalis, and the arcuate.
So you're going to see
this over and over again.
There's not too many
things to remember here.
But it will grow,
because I will have
to talk about more
and more areas
as we progress in the course.
Now, here is area V1.
And as I pointed
out to you before,
this region is in the
monkey lissencephalic,
meaning it's mostly flat.
And because of that,
its spatial layout
is fairly easy to understand.
So the first thing
you want to do
is to understand this spatial
layout of the structure.
And to do that people have
done all sorts of experiments.
Here is one that has
done the spatial layout.
Initially, the way
this was done was
kind of a difficult undertaking.
They used single
microelectrodes,
and they would systematically
move the microelectrodes here,
and all across.
And then they would map out
where the receptive field was.
OK?
So if they did that, they
found that in this region
here the fovea is represented.
And then as you progress towards
the center of the brain, what
you find is the center of the
hemisphere I should really say.
You progress to
about 80 degrees out.
And this is the
horizontal meridian.
And this below
here, and above it,
is the vertical meridian
that goes around.
OK?
So what is represented,
as you had already seen,
you're representing
each hemisphere,
half the visual field.
So what you have is this.
OK?
This is the horizontal meridian.
This is the upper part.
This is the lower part.
OK?
But that is inverted
on the retina,
as well is inverted
on the visual cortex.
All right.
So that's the basic layout.
But now what happened, as it
always happens in science,
new methods were
developed to study
this in more detail,
and more reliably.
And one of the methods
that was developed
is to do a combined action,
and then chemical experiment,
in which the eyes
were stimulated.
Then they were fixed, and one
of the neurons were active.
Took up the substance
that was injected
into the bloodstream, which then
could be labeled subsequently.
So I'm going to show you
what this arrangement is.
This is what the
monkey is looking at.
This is the half of
the visual field that
is being studied,
because you're looking
at the contralateral hemisphere.
And then what is being
done in these experiments
is that you alternate the
black and white stripes
back and forth.
So you can see if that's
sort of a flicker.
And you keep doing this
for an hour or two.
And as a result
of this, the cells
that are activated
by this take up
this substance
that is being used,
which is called
2DG, 2-Deoxyglucose.
And then subsequently
you can label that.
So now what we are
going to do, we
can look at what the
label looks like.
And here is this beautiful
example of this work.
Here is a foveal area.
This is about 7
or 8 degrees out.
OK?
So if you go back-- oops.
Sorry.
This outermost half disk
is one that you see here.
OK?
So now we have a very
clear understanding,
which we can do quantitatively,
of what the spatial layout is
of the visual field on
the retinal surface.
And one important point that
I want you to remember today,
and we will discuss
it again when
we talk about visual prosthesis,
is that much more brain area
is devoted to central vision,
because of course the many more
cells in the fovea
than in the periphery.
And the cortex itself is
of constant thickness.
It's about roughly 2
millimeters in thickness.
And so you need to
give it more space
in this lissencephalic
brain to accept
all that input from
the foveal region.
And so much more area is
devoted to foveal vision
than to peripheral vision.
All right.
So that then is
the spatial layout.
And then if we look
at a cross section
of the visual
cortical regions here,
this includes several cortical
areas, this one right here,
and this region here
is so-called area V1.
Now, an interesting
discovery was
made by a person
called Gennari, who
discovered when he used
this kind of Nissl stain
that when you look at V1,
there seems to be almost
what looks like an extra
stripe, which gets labeled.
And as soon as we get here,
as you can see, this point,
it stops here.
And that defines, this extra
layer, this stria of Gennari
defines area 17 anatomically.
If you get here, you
suddenly get to area V2,
so V2 starts here.
So even with a simple
anatomical technique,
you can tell what is area
V1, and area V2, and so on.
OK.
So now, if we take a cross
section of the visual cortex,
which I've said is about 2
millimeters in thickness, OK?
People have divided this region,
this so-called gray matter.
Why is it called gray matter?
It's called gray matter,
because most of the cells
there are not coded.
Whereas if you go below, you
have all the coded fibers
that are coming in.
So this gray matter
then has been
divided into six subdivisions.
Layers one through six.
In this case from the
top down instead of
in the genicular point,
so from the bottom up.
And these layers,
subsequently, were
realized they're more
than six layers, really.
And that's why it became
4A, 4B, 4CF, or 4C-beta.
Now the 4C-alpha and beta is a
region that gets a lot of input
directly from the lateral
geniculate nucleus.
And what the nature
of that input is,
I'm going to show you here.
Once again, here's the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
The six layers.
The four parvocellular, and
two magnocellular layers.
And then what we can do, is
we can trace how that connect.
This has been done both
physiologically and
anatomically.
And it shows that the
four top layers terminate
for the most part, almost
exclusive, but not 100%,
but pretty closely into
layers of so-called 4C-alpha.
Whereas when you come to
the two bottom layers, OK?
The so-called
magnocellular layers,
they terminate in 4C-beta.
So some of these
things are almost
like an inversion
from here to there.
OK?
And then another
thing we haven't
talked about before is that also
some cells, even though they're
not numerous, that reside
in between the layers
of the lateral
geniculate nucleus,
are called the
koniocellular cells.
But you don't have to
worry about that now.
You don't have to remember
that at this point.
But we'll talk about it later.
But when you do look
at them, what you find
is that they project
into the upper part
of the visual cortex, both from
the parvocellular interlaminar
layers, and the magnocellular
interlaminar layers.
So as you might
expect, things are
complicated when it
comes to the brain.
And there are just all
kinds of connections,
and you're trying
to make sense of it,
and understand the reasons as to
why we have these connections,
and what the functions are.
All right.
So now, we are going to take
a big step forward, and begin
to look at the functional
aspects of area V1.
OK?
Oops.
Sorry.
Hang on.
Here we are.
We are going to look
at the receptive field
organization of cells.
So how do you do that?
What you do is you can stick
either a single electrode,
or multiple electrodes
into the visual cortex.
And then you can map
out the receptive fields
to see how they respond.
OK?
Now, this was an
interesting story
in the beginning when
this kind of search
went on, because there were two
major groups that were trying
to understand what the
visual responses are
like in the visual cortex.
And this was not
even that long ago.
This was in the
1930s, '40s, and '50s.
So what was done in
two areas, and one
was in Germany,
what they did there,
they kind of followed in the
spirit of Keffer Hartline.
And they shone light into
the eye, diffused light.
And they recorded from V1, and
they couldn't derive any cells
to the extent that
some people said,
I think people have
made a major mistake.
That stuff back here,
that's not a visual area.
It's something else.
But then, pretty much at the
same time, another group,
initially at Johns Hopkins,
and subsequently at Harvard,
did similar experiments.
But what happened was, it's
almost an amusing story.
The people who did that
were Hubel and Wiesel.
And when they first
went to Johns Hopkins,
they worked with a
person's name I've
mentioned before,
I think, Kuffler,
who discovered
center-surround antagonism.
And Kuffler did experiments
similar in technique,
in terms of activating
the eye, that
had been done by Keffer
Hartline, which shine light
into the eye.
Not necessarily diffused
light, but spots of light
that he would move around
on the retinal surface.
This was a very complicated
piece of equipment.
And so when Hubel and Wiesel
went to become postdocs
with Kuffler, they said,
my god, what is this?
We don't know how
to work this stuff.
Let's do something different,
so we can handle it.
And so what they decided to
do, and this may sound crazy--
Let me explain one more thing.
When these experiments were
done in the cat, with the way
the experiment was
done, that the cat was
put upside down on
a table like this.
Like that.
And the light was shone into it.
OK?
With a piece of
equipment from above,
and you could even look
at it through a microscope
to see how that light
was shone into the eye.
So Hubel and Wiesel said,
you can't handle this.
But I tell you what
we'll do instead.
You'll take a bed sheet, and
put it up on the ceiling.
And then we'll take a projector,
and move the light around
like this.
OK?
Now, the projector they used was
like an old fashioned camera.
And you could put
a slide in there,
and move the slide in and out.
OK?
And so they would,
first of all, just
had the whole lights come on.
And they kept recording, and
they wouldn't get anything.
They said, oh my god.
Those people in
Germany are right.
These cells don't
respond to light.
What's going on?
And then one day, as they were
fiddling around with this,
Torsten Wiesel
pulled out a slide
to put a different slide in.
And when he pulled
that slide out,
they displayed the sound
of the action potentials.
Like that.
What on earth was that?
And so they did it repeated.
[HIGH-PITCHED BEEPING SOUND]
Like that.
And guess what that resulted in?
That finding [INAUDIBLE] logic
that resulted in the Nobel
Prize he and Hubel got,
because they discovered
that cells' individual cortex
are orientation selective.
OK?
Meaning that each cell responds
to a particular orientation
of an edge.
And this was an
incredible transformation,
which we saw in the
retina, and what
you had seen in the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
So what they then did, they
became systematic about it,
and mapped out the receptive
field organization of cells.
And they discovered two
majors classes of cells,
they called the simple
cells, and the complex cells.
The simple cells were
distinctive in the sense,
first of all, all
these types of cells
were orientation specific.
I want to find the
appropriate orientation
by moving the edge around until
you get the best response.
Then you could do
the very small spot.
You could activate
the cell, but not as
effectively as with the ball
moving, of course, but still
quite well.
And they found that
there was a center
region in this kind of simple
cell that gave an on response,
and a surround region
that gave an off response.
And then they
found another class
of simple cells, in which the
left half in this case was on,
and the right half was off.
And there were
variations of this,
I'll mention those in a
bit more detail later,
indicating that the input
from the on and off systems
may be separate, or they
[? sub ?] some interaction
that makes for their
specificity for orientation.
Now then, they also discovered
another class of cells called
complex that on the
whole tended to have
a bit larger receptive fields.
And in these cells, even
when you use small spots,
no matter where
you stimulate it,
you got both on and off
responses intermingled.
So you did not have
a spatial separation
of the on and the off responses.
Now what exactly we mean
by on and off responses
we will discuss for the
whole session next time.
OK.
So now, let me explain to you
how you do these experiments.
Once you get a little bit more
sophisticated, and instead
of just using a projector
that you reflect the light
with by hand, you can
do this on a computer.
OK?
And that indeed was
a big step forward.
I would say in the early 1960s,
maybe late '50s or early '60s,
people became computerized as
we had especially here at MIT.
And the first set of computers
that were used to enable us
to quantitatively measure these
attributes in the visual cortex
were the so-called PDP-11/10s.
Subsequently, PDP-11/20s.
Subsequently then PDP-11/34s.
Some of you may have heard about
these ancient old computers
that practically
nobody uses anymore,
because of all the
advances that have
been made in
computer technology.
So what you did then
using a variety of means,
I don't have to describe
that in detail, is
to move a bar of light
across the receptive
field in different orientations.
So here's an example here.
You first use very
small spots, and you
find the receptive field.
And then after,
because the cells
do respond to very
small spots of light.
But they don't respond
at all to larger spots.
And once you've found
the receptive field, what
you can do is you
can take a bar,
and move it across it in
different orientations,
like this.
So here's a direct example.
Like that.
OK?
So as soon as it's
been across the field,
the cell responded vigorously.
And so if we then did
it systematically,
as I've shown here, you can
generate an orientation tuning
function, it is called.
So you can quantitatively
establish just
how sharply specific
a cell like this
is to different orientations.
So to do that here is an
example of that in a second.
Here is an example.
What you can see here is
when you move the ball down,
you get a huge response here.
And then we get rapidly
progressively less
of a response.
And then you can establish
by taking the half height,
or whatever point here, what
the width is of this function.
And then you can plot
that for hundreds of cells
to establish just how
sharply they are tuned,
or how different types of cells,
say simple and complex, how
sharp they are tuned.
Now, that was only
quite amazing.
But then if you
look at this figure,
I want you guys to be
my best detectives.
I bet you all of you are
best detectives, right?
So if you are, you
have to tell me
what else is in this figure
that tells you something
more about this cell that
is not just orientation.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Also, the
direction as well.
PROFESSOR: A-ha.
There we go.
Best detective.
OK.
Is that your middle name?
Best detective?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Very good.
So what you see here,
if this cell only
were orientation selective, you
should get another peak here,
because you have the
same orientation,
but moving upward, like this.
OK?
But you don't have
anything like that.
So what does that mean?
That means that this
particular cell is not
only orientation specific, but
it is also direction specific.
Now that's quite something.
And the overwhelming
majority of cells
in the visual cortex in V1 are
direction selective, as well,
in addition to being
orientation selective.
And then when you
go to other areas,
as we'll see in
just a minute, there
are some areas in which
virtually all the cells
are direction selective.
So direction cell
activity becomes
an inherent central attribute
of visual processing,
as revealed by the fact that all
the cells, I shouldn't say all,
but so many of the cells
in the visual cortex
have that attribute.
OK.
So now, what we can do
is ask the next question.
Now, are there other
attributes in the cells
of the visual cortex that
are selective [INAUDIBLE]
some other attribute
of the visual scene?
So far we have orientation,
and we have direction.
So another one that
has been studied
is spatial frequency
selectivity.
Now, how do you do that?
The most common way
this had been done
is to use sinusoidal gratings.
An example of that
is shown here.
But you could use also
[? square-wave ?] gradings,
or sinusoidal gratings work
extremely well for a variety
of reasons.
We will talk about that later.
And what you do
then on each trial,
as you move this back and
forth across the receptive
field in the
optimal orientation,
you can vary the
spatial frequency.
You can make it extremely
high, or extremely low.
This is obviously very low.
OK?
And if you do that
systematically once again,
using a computer system that
can establish to what degree
are cells specific to
different spatial frequencies.
Everybody understand that?
OK.
So let me show you what happens.
Here is an example
of a simple cell,
and here's an example
of a complex cell.
Here we have different spatial
frequencies on each line,
as specified in here.
And it shows that both
of these types of cells
respond to some in-between
level of spatial frequency
selectivity, and don't
respond at the extremes.
So that means that these
cortical cells, in addition
to being orientation
and direction selective,
are also spatial
frequency selective.
And that had lead to
many interesting ideas
about what is the coding
operation in the visual cortex
that enables you to see.
And that we will
discuss some more later.
OK.
The other important feature
here that is worth mentioning
is that simple cells respond
selectively to each phase,
whereas complex cells respond
in a more general fashion.
OK?
All right.
So now, we can
summarize, and I'm
going to add a couple
more things to it,
of what the major
so-called transforms are
in the visual cortex.
And this is remarkable as
you go from the geniculate
to the visual cortex,
and suddenly there
are all these
transforms that somehow
will enable you to
see things better.
So the first one of course,
we talked about a lot,
is orientation.
Next one is direction.
Then spatial frequency.
Those are the three I
gave you examples of.
But now, one thing I
haven't mentioned so far
is that you have
also a transform
in terms of binocularity.
As I mentioned to you that
already, in the geniculate
you have specificity
by layers of input
from the left and
right eyes, which
means that those cells
in each of those layers
are driven only by one eye.
OK?
They have a monocular.
But now when you come
up to the cortex,
the numerous cells once you
get above the major input
layers, 4CL from there or
below, most of the cells
there can be driven
binocularly, meaning
they get an input
from both eyes.
And we shall examine
what that is.
And another thing that
we have that you already
must have inferred on the
basis looking at the receptive
fields, that there is a
dramatic ON/OFF convergence.
In complex terms,
it's so complete
that it's totally intermingled.
So the cell responds to on and
off by the way you present it.
The simple cells also
respond to on and off,
but there's a small
spatial separation
between the on and
off sub region.
Now in addition, that we
will encounter also later,
some of the cells,
not all of the cells,
but some of the cells
in the visual cortex
get a convergent in both the
midget and parasol cells,
while others get an input
only from one or the other.
So that further highlights
the extensive increase
of complexity, and
analysis that is
being performed in
the visual cortex.
OK.
So now, to sort of schematize
about this, what we can say
is the following.
We can say here is
that we have a cell
in primary visual cortex, in V1.
OK?
And many of these
cells, most of them,
get an input from both the
left and the right eyes,
as shown here.
They also get an
input, many of them,
that are convergent from the
parasol and midget system.
And then the output
of these cells,
in some fashion or
other, should be
able to tell us, either
from the same cell
or from separate cells
that we've examined,
tell us about luminance, color,
orientation, spatial frequency,
depth and motion.
So those are some of the major
tasks a cortical cell performs,
so that you can see.
So that then is a
very general scheme
that we are then
going to examine
in considerably more detail.
All right.
So now, we take
another step forward.
The question came up.
How are these things in general,
these attributes and whatnot,
arranged in the visual cortex?
Is everything just
helter skelter,
or is there spatial separation
among various attributes?
And this is yet another
major line of research
that Hubel and Wiesel had done,
for which they got the Nobel
Prize, as well as for
their other discoveries.
I think they got the Nobel
Prize in 1983, I believe it was.
OK.
So this is called
cytoarchitecture.
OK?
Your ability to understand what
the layout is of the functional
attributes of the cells
in the visual cortex.
All right.
So let me, first
of all, tell you
the initial experiment
Hubel and Wiesel had done.
What they did is they would
inject a label into one eye.
And then if they
waited a week or so,
you would get
transneuronal transport,
meaning that the label
would go to the geniculate,
and that label would transport
to the cells in the geniculate,
and then would go up
to the visual cortex.
And so when they looked
at this, put the input
into the left eye,
what they found
was in the cortex of
the cat in this case,
you see these
alternations, you can
label them unlabeled regions.
And the labels in
unlabeled regions
are pretty much
equally distributed.
The assumption therefore is,
and that was proven of course,
that if you were to
label both sides,
then you would get
a continuous label.
These include areas, or if
you labeled the other eye,
you would get the
dark areas labeled.
So this established then that
we have an orderly arrangement
of, if you will, ocular
dominance columns.
That's what it is called.
Ocular dominance columns.
Now, this is a cross section.
So now, what you can do is
do a similar experiment.
Unless you're doing
a cross section,
you can take the brain, and
make horizontal cuts across it.
Now, the brain is slightly
curved, of course,
depending on the
species how much.
And so, when you make these
very thin cross sections,
they will only tell you about
that particular cross section.
But then you can
put them together.
You can take a montage.
So let me explain that to you.
Here is a single
section of the left eye
columns that are
labeled in the monkey.
So in other words to
repeat, you inject a label
into the left eye.
Then that is transported
transneuronally
to the visual cortex, and
this is how it lights up.
But now what you
can do is you can
take each of these sections.
There are many sections.
I told you the cortex is about
2 millimeters in thickness.
OK?
So we can take a huge
number of sections
across, depending on how thick
or thin you want to cut it.
And then you can
label each of these,
and then you can
superimpose them.
And this is what
we call a montage.
In this case we have five layers
that have been superimposed,
so you can see it.
Now, these columns
here, so-called, it's
a column because it goes through
the thickness of the cortex,
are then ocular
dominance columns.
OK?
Ocular dominance columns.
We will next examine
whether they're also
columns for orientation.
That's why I said orientation.
OK.
Anyway, so we have
this arrangement.
And these often have been
called zebra stripes,
because it looks like a zebra.
And that helps as a mnemonic
device to remember this.
Now, what you can
do is to examine
this a bit more systematically.
And if you do that,
we can draw together
a huge section of
the visual cortex.
This is the fovea
again, in this case.
This is about 80 degrees out.
And so this is a section that
was put together in the Hubel
Wiesel Laboratory at
Harvard, showing you
that the thickness of them
is constant throughout.
And then to understand what
they're talking about in terms
of size, here we have
David Hubel's thumbprint.
OK?
So if you look at
your thumbprint,
the spatial frequency here
is about twice roughly,
twice that you have here.
So again, if you look
at your thumb like this,
it can give you a sense
of how unbelievably fine
these columns are in
the visual cortex.
OK?
So that's basically the layout.
So now, the next big
question came up in the work
that Hubel and Wiesel
originally did,
was whether you also had
columns for orientation.
So how do you do that?
Well, another
technique has evolved,
and everything that you
discover in this business
heavily depends on you
being able to come up
with a new technique,
or somebody else,
and use a technique
they invented.
And when you do that,
almost inevitably you
can make a major discovery.
But if you're not sensitive
to new technologies,
then it's unlikely
that you're going
to make a major new discovery.
So you've got to keep your
nose to the grindstone,
and constantly
look, and say what
is the latest discovery
in many techniques.
All right.
So if you do that, one of the
remarkable techniques that
had been developed
is to use a substance
called 2-deoxyglucose
that I'm not
going to go into
details about it.
It's radioactively
labeled as well,
and what you inject
in the bloodstream.
And then what happens is that
those cells in the brain that
are highly active, absorb
more of this 2-deoxyglucose
than those cells
that are inactive.
And so if you do
that, the experiment
you would do to look at the
selectivity for orientation,
is you take an animal,
unless it is paralyzed,
and present for an hour
vertically oriented set
of bars, or signs of
gratings that keep moving,
and keep moving,
and keep moving.
And then those cells that are,
in this case going this way,
have selected the
horizontal orientation.
Those will take up a lot
more of this 2-deoxyglucose,
and therefore that would
be heavily labeled.
So then the question is,
what does that look like?
And so if you do that
kind of experiment,
let me skip that, here's
an experiment like that,
and this happens to
be the tree shrew.
It shows that in
this case, when you
use one particular
orientation that you
get these stripes, which
reflect those cells
in the visual cortex in
the column arrangement
that respond best
to that orientation.
So therefore, if
this is horizontal,
the ones in between with
these cells are vertical.
All right?
So if you then do this
systematically in the monkey,
you can see exactly
what that looks like.
And then you can ask the
big question that was posed.
What is the relationship between
orientation selectivity columns
and ocular dominance columns?
So that was then done
by a set of experiments,
also in the
Hubel-Wiesel Laboratory.
And I'm proud to say
that the prime person who
did that experiment was one
of my former students, who
got his PhD in my
laboratory, Michael Stryker.
And so he did these experiments.
And so in a way,
the experiment was
done to test a
hypothesis that was
proposed by Huber and Wiesel.
And let me interject
at this point, that one
of the important
things to realize
is that you do not want to fall
in love with your hypotheses,
because in most cases the
hypothesis that you dream up,
so to speak, out of
thin air, will end up
being wrong when it
comes to the brain.
So in this case,
this also happened.
This is the model
they came up with.
They proposed that you had
what we call an ice cube
model, which in one direction
specifies orientation columns,
and in the other direction,
ocular dominance columns.
So this is the ice cube model.
And now that you had this
model, this hypothesis,
you could test it.
And the way this was tested
was to use the same procedures
I described to you, but
do it in the same brain.
All right?
And so here's an example of here
we have a part of the brain,
again looking at it
from the top down, which
had been labeled for both
orientation and ocular
dominance columns.
And then you take
that same brain,
and you label it for
orientation columns.
So now, if your hypothesis is
correct, let me clarify this,
if you say that they are
right angles to each other,
then you would expect that if
you have a bunch of orientation
columns, the ocular
dominance columns
should be at right angles to it.
Right?
And so if you label this,
and then can draw it out,
you can see whether or not
that hypothesis is correct.
And when you did that, here is
a real example of what they did.
One of these is orientation,
and the thick ones
and the thin ones is ocular
dominant, maybe the other way
around.
It doesn't matter.
But at any rate, if the
hypothesis is correct,
you'll expect something
like what you see here.
They're at right
angles to each other.
OK?
But if you look at
it carefully, you
can see the endless
locations where they're not
at right angles to each other.
All right?
And because of that, even
though that's a very attractive
hypothesis, people have come
up with other hypotheses saying
that this hypothesis
is really questionable.
And an alternative hypothesis
that had been proposed
arose in part by yet another new
discovery that had been made.
And this discovery
was made by a woman
called Margaret Wong-Riley.
But this particular picture
has been done by processing,
again this is a horizontal
view looking down at the brain,
by Marge Livingstone,
who is at Harvard,
and had done all the
collaborative work with Hubel.
So what you see here, are the
so-called cytochrome oxidase
patches.
OK?
Now, when this was
first discovered,
people said, my god.
They had never seen
anything like this before.
This is the only kind of
stain that showed this up.
Let me explain to you.
This is also an activity label.
The cytochrome oxidase.
And we selectively label those
cells that are most active,
rather than those cells
which are inactive.
And so this is what
these patches look like.
And so people kept saying,
why do we have this patches?
We've never seen them
before in the visual cortex.
What on earth are they for?
What do they tell us about?
So all kinds of
hypotheses evolved.
And people asked the question,
since we have this thing, what
if we recorded in
one of these patches,
as opposed to outside of them.
And so when this was
done by several people--
let me just show you if you
have a much larger section.
Here again is a fovea
that's about 80 degrees out.
This is what these
patches look like when
you do it on the high contrast.
OK?
So indeed, they're
extremely frequent.
They're very orderly.
And so the question, of course,
is whether these batches
are relative to the columns
that we talked about.
And what was
discovered, it if you
look at the ocular
dominance columns,
these patches are always
in the middle of a column.
So in other words,
to make that clear,
if you have here a
column like that,
the patches would be like this.
OK?
And the next one over, again
the patches would be like that.
OK?
They would not be
between patches.
So there's a direct relationship
between the ocular dominance
columns, and the layout
of these patches.
OK?
All right.
So now, as a result
of this work,
people have come up
with yet, and let
me finish, another
hypothesis, which
is called the radio model.
They argued that
the cells that are
in the center of these patches
are largely unoriented,
and that the orientation
selectivity goes around
in a radio fashion, as indicated
here in the visual cortex
within each of the
ocular dominance columns.
OK?
AUDIENCE: I'm good now.
PROFESSOR: Are you good now?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
PROFESSOR: All right.
So that's the second
model that has emerged.
And this model also
was highly questioned,
because the evidence
was not that you
had these nice clear radio
orientations for orientation
selectivity.
So then finally
another technique
had emerged, which
was carried out again
at Harvard, at Harvard Medical
School by a fellow called
Blaisdell.
He developed a technique
that actually other people
have used, but
then he applied it
to the visual cortex, that
is called optical recording.
So you could record optically
from the visual cortex
straight down, and then
it could vary orientation,
and ocular dominance.
And when you did
that, this is what
a typical example looks like.
OK?
Those red lines show what the
layout is of the orientation
selectivity of the cells,
and the patches here
are those regions
where you don't
have orientation selectivity.
OK?
So this then indicated
that you do not
have a computer like layout
in the visual cortex going
one way, and the other way
for orientation direction.
But you have it a bit messier.
And so this particular
arrangement then was called,
or at least I called
it, the swirl model.
OK?
But actually, to call
it a model is incorrect.
This is a fact.
The others are models.
OK?
So now to put it all together,
here is the Hubel and Wiesel
ice-cube model, where the
orientation selectivity
[INAUDIBLE] right
angles to each other.
Then we have the radio model.
And finally we have
the swirl model,
which is the way it really is.
All right.
So that then in
essence tells you
about the cytoarchitecture
of the visual cortex.
Now we are going to take
another big step forward.
We are going to look
at extrastriate cortex.
As I've mentioned
to you before, when
you look at the
visual cortex, it
comes actually in many
subdivisions, and maybe
as many as 30 visual
cortical areas,
of which we will only
talk about a few of them,
because it's totally
overwhelming.
And these areas were presumed
to involve, maybe correctly so,
initially at least, increasingly
complex visual analyses.
All right?
Now, one of the
prime ideas that,
or hypotheses again if
you will, to my mind
turned out to be incorrect,
is that each of these areas
in the brain
specializes in analyzing
a certain aspect of vision.
So what are certain
aspects of vision?
Just a few examples
are analyzing color,
analyzing shape, analyzing
motion, and so on.
And so they argue that
all these visual areas
specialize in one of those.
So that was an interesting
idea, and so people
began to study extrastriate
cortex in more detail.
And I'm going to say
few words about it,
but let me go back even
further in history.
Let's go back to a time
in the early 1800s.
There were two very
famous people there,
which were called
Gall and Spurzheim.
And they came up
with the idea which
eventually was
called phrenology.
How many of know phrenology?
Oh, well.
My goodness.
All of you do.
OK.
So phrenology, in
essence, claimed
that there are specific areas
in the brain, as shown here,
that specialize in certain
aspects of the information
processing.
And how did they
come up with this?
The way they came up with
it was to palpate the skull.
And wherever there
were big bulges,
they felt that there
was a lot of that
attribute that a person had.
And if it was small,
then the person
didn't have too much of it.
And so they played with
it, and played with it,
and they came up in
an 1812 publication
with essentially 35 basic
visual attributes of processing
in the brain, for the cortex
of the brain in humans.
And the interesting
thing about this
is it gives you a
sense of history
and how much we have
changed in our lives,
as to what these specialized
areas were conceived to be.
Now, to make that a little
bit clearer for you,
let me stop here for a second.
And what I want to do here
is I want to enlarge this,
so you can see it better.
OK.
So here are some of these areas.
And if you look at these, you
will be almost taken aback
as to what the hell
the names are here.
I mean, some of the common names
here that you can see would be,
for example, let's see if I
can put them in the right order
here.
Actually, the thing was that
they called these not only
propensities, but they
called them sentiments.
So in those days sentiments
were very important.
There's not much brain
allocated to sentiments anymore.
But at any rate,
such things that
existed as amativeness,
cautiousness, benevolence,
veneration, wonder and ideality.
Those are just a few examples
here that you can spot.
Amativeness right there.
And indeed you can
ask the question,
really would that much brain
be devoted to amativeness?
And certainly that's
not the case anymore.
So maybe our brains are
totally different from the way
they were back in 1812.
I doubt it.
And so therefore, I think these
things are rather fanciful,
and very far-fetched hypotheses.
And as I mentioned before,
that's par for the course.
So many hypotheses
end up being wrong,
and the best way
to overcome that is
to do solid experiments to find
out what is really going on.
OK.
So now, we move on.
And we need to understand what
the more modern techniques are
that enable us to specify
things about these higher
cortical areas.
The first one of these
is architectonics.
That's obvious what it is.
That's simply to
look at the brain,
and identify the various
areas in a systematic fashion.
The second one is to
look at connections.
You do anatomical
studies to determine
which areas to connect to
what areas in what fashion.
Another one is
topographic mapping.
We talked about that already.
One of those was to actually
do single cell recording
systematically moving
the electrode across,
or to do the two
digit type studies.
Another one we can
do is what we call
physiological characterization.
That's also known to you.
When you looked at
the cells in V1,
you established that
they're orientation
direction selective.
That's your physiological
characterization
of the cells in V1.
And then you can ask
the question, well,
what about V2, V4, and
so on, these other areas.
What are the cells like there?
What do they respond to well?
And so on.
And then, another very
important technique
is to say, OK, what if we
removed a particular area that
had been identified.
What kind of loss do
you have in vision,
or in general in the brain?
If you move a particular area,
what kind of deficit arises?
And if that's a
specific deficit,
you can infer that that
particular area plays
an important role
in the analysis
that you can no longer do.
That can also be done instead
of making specific lesions.
It's less accurate,
but you can do it
by studying humans who
have had various kinds
of febrile accidents.
And that's one of the things
that our former chairman,
Hans-Lukas Teuber,
has done extensively.
Studying people after
the Second World
War who have sustained
specific brain injuries to see
what kinds of deficits they had
suffered on the basis of that
you could infer what
various brain areas do.
And the last one here
that I want to mention
is imaging, of course.
We've talked about that.
You can present certain specific
stimuli to activate the brain.
And then once you process
that using magnetic resonance
imaging, for example, functional
magnetic resonance imaging can
tell you how
important, for example,
areas are in recognising faces.
And some of that work is
being done, actually here,
by Nancy Kanwisher, for
example, in our department.
OK.
So to do this then
systematically,
you have to have a sort of
idea of what kinds of functions
do we want to study.
And so you want to break
it down visual functions.
And one way to break
them down, I'm not
saying this is overall
satisfactory to everyone,
they can talk about so-called
basic visual capacities,
and more higher level ones.
When you talk about
basic visual capacities,
they say well how well
can you see color.
How well can you distinguish
differences in brightness?
How good are you at
seeing basic patterns?
Textures?
Motion?
Depth?
OK?
So those would be your
basic visual functions.
And then when you come to
intermediate visual capacities,
things become much more
complex, of course.
You come up with constancy.
How come that when I look
at something that's nearby,
and something
that's further way,
I can recognize
it's the same thing?
OK?
Or how can we select
things in the visual scene?
How can we recognize things,
just like recognizing faces?
How can we make transpositions?
How can we make comparisons?
And how can we locate
things in space?
So those would be some of those
so-called intermediate visual
capacities.
And I'm not even going
to mention high level
visual capacities, because
they are even more complicated,
and we know even
less about them.
OK.
So now, let's go and lay
out the visual areas.
Just the very basics
of it, because it's
unbelievably complicated.
Here we have a human brain.
And back when this
was put together,
this posterior area here, which
is the primary visual cortex,
called area 17 then,
we now call that V1.
And 18 would be V2.
And 19, V3, and so on.
OK.
So now again, we go back
to the monkey brain.
And when we look at the monkey
brain, what you see here
is again the central sulcus.
You're going to see this
over and over again,
and it's going to
stick into your head.
Here's the lunate sulcus.
And here is area V1.
This is where we had examined
the properties of these cells
that we had just talked about.
Then if you move on, right at
the edge here of the lunate,
V2 starts, and then goes
from under the gyrus.
And then in this region here,
we have what is called area V4.
So those are some
of the basic areas.
And you are going to see
a few things about them.
Now, people have studied
this extensively,
and they came up with
frightening diagrams of this.
This is a flattened
monkey brain.
This is V1.
And then you have a
whole bunch of areas
that are following
succession here.
I'm not going to
label many of these.
And we talked about V2, V4.
But there are many, many more.
I'll bring up a few
more in a minute.
And then, if you look at
the interconnections that
had been made, it's
totally frightening.
There's so many hundreds,
and hundreds, and hundreds
of connections going
every which way.
So it is very difficult to say
that particular area receives
inputs only from one other
area, or something like that.
There's just a tremendous
amount of interconnections,
indicating that any analysis is
likely to take place involving
thousands, and tens of thousands
of thousands of neurons being
active in many, many
different brain areas.
OK.
Now the major cortical visual
areas that we shall consider
are V1, that we already
did, V2, V3, V4 and MT.
Then in the temporal
region of the brain,
we have inferotemporal cortex.
And then in the
private region, we
have the lateral intraparietal
area, the ventral area,
and MST, which is called the
Medial Superior Temporal area.
And then lastly, in
the frontal lobe,
we have the frontal eye fields.
Now, we will talk
about each of these
at various levels in the course.
Today, we will just briefly
talk about V2, V4 and MT.
OK.
So now, a couple of
general principles
that emerge from
this kind of work.
First of all is that the
size of the receptive
fields in these different
areas changes dramatically.
In the visual cortex there's
aptitudes that are very small.
I mean, bigger
than in the retina,
or in the geniculate, but
still very, very small.
But then when you
get to V2, they're
about three times bigger
on the average in diameter.
And when you come
to V4, they're huge.
OK?
And that's true throughout,
that the specificity
of the location of
the receptive fields
decreases as you progress up
into higher cortical areas.
Now, there's another
very interesting fact
that had been discovered, which
again nobody hypothesized.
Namely, that the way these areas
are laid out next to each other
is not what you
would have thought.
So let me give you an example.
Suppose what we do is we take
an electrode, and record in V1,
and then we go in
progressive steps across V1,
where the receptive fields
move out from the fovea
into the periphery.
And if you do that,
here's a receptive field
of that cell.
[INAUDIBLE], right there.
The next one is a little
bit further removed.
And here's the next one,
and that one is there.
OK?
So what you have
is a progression
of receptive fields.
They get bigger, and they
move from the center out.
So now the big question
is what happens
when you now come in to V2.
And think about it for a minute.
What do you think?
Where do you think
the receptive field
will be when you just ride
across from V1 to V2 in the map
that I had shown you before?
Well, you will be surprised.
I think you will be surprised.
You will find that the next
receptive field, close as this,
is at the same location, almost,
very close the same location.
And of course, the
receptive field
is about three times bigger.
Now, what happens when
you now move one over?
Well, the receptive field
comes back towards the center.
And again, and again like that.
So these areas connect to each
other in reverse, so to speak.
In other words, if they didn't
one would connect to here.
Two would connect
to there, and so on.
But instead, four and five
could have short connections.
Three and six,
longer, and so on.
So we have this very
curious arrangement.
And to this day I
don't have a clue
as to why in the course of
evolution this happened.
I mean, there all
kinds of hypotheses.
This may take less
elaborate wiring.
Not as long wiring
overall, or something,
because if it were
the other way,
then all these
wires would be long.
So that could be a reason,
but one is not sure.
And to my knowledge,
no experiment
has yet been done
to truly explain
why we have this
curious arrangement.
Now, when you look
at area V2, we
have yet another very
interesting factor.
When you come back to area
V1, this would use V1.
We have those famous
cytochrome oxidase patches.
But then when you get to area
V2, instead of what you have,
you have these elongated bars.
OK?
And if you look
closely, you can see
that there's a
tendency for the bars
to go from thick to thin
with an inter-bar area.
And so when this was
discovered, people
began to record to say why
is this different from here.
What does it signify?
And so when they did
that systematically,
they came up with a model, which
may not be entirely correct.
But the claim was that
the thin stripes in V2
get inputs
predominantly from there
patches that you have in V1.
And the thick stripes get input
from the so-called parasol
system, meaning that they
would be heavily involved
in things like what
the parasol cells do,
namely play an important
role in emotion perception.
And the interstripes
here called,
or the pale stripes sometimes
called, they get input
in this particular model from
the orientation specific cells.
OK?
So now, once this was
done and proposed,
people begin to do
experiments to record
in the thick and
thin stripes of V2
to see what the properties
are of the cells
there, recognizing of course
that the size of the receptive
fields is uniformly about
three times bigger than in V1.
So when they did that,
they looked at orientation.
And they found that in
V2, most of the cells
in the thick stripes are
orientation specific, but also
many in the thin stripes, and
many also in the pale stripes.
So there didn't seem to
be a huge distinction.
Then when it came
to end stopping,
I didn't talk about that.
Let me mention what
end stopping means.
If you take a bar of
light, and you move it
across a receptive field,
you get a vigorous response
when it's a fairly short bar.
But then when you make
the bar a lot longer,
you get less of a
response, because
of some surrounding [INAUDIBLE].
So that's what's called, by
Hubel and Wiesel, end stopping.
And so that
attribute is one that
is again fairly similar
in the three areas.
When you come to color,
in the thin stripes
there is much more
color sensitivity
than the fixed stripes.
When it comes to direction,
again not that much difference.
Maybe more in the thick stripes.
Disparity, more in thickness.
Disparity refers to
depth perception,
as we have talked about.
So the prime message
here is that you do not
have a complete clear separation
of function in those three
stripes that had been
identified in V2,
virtually inputs from V1.
So now, we are going
to move on to V4.
And when you talk
about area of V4,
we'll talk about that again
in more detail later on.
We have a huge
increase of complexity
of the response
properties of cells.
And here is area
V4, as you can see.
A lot of recording has
been done in this area.
Hundreds of papers
have been published.
And I can conclude
on the basis of that.
First of all, here
the receptive fields
are even a lot
bigger than in V2.
And the receptive
field properties
are far more complex
than in either V1 or V2.
And the response
properties are dynamic.
If the monkey is
paying attention,
or is looking for
something, the cells
will find a lot more than when
he's not looking for something.
And yet another
discovery was made
that the amount of
activity is also
modulated by how you move your
eyes as you're looking around
in the visual scene.
And then, an important
conclusion from that
is that this is not
just a color area.
And the reason I mention that
is because a good many years
ago an experiment
was done in England.
I shan't name the
person who was doing it,
who claimed that
this is a color area.
Now, one of the reasons
he made that claim
was that he removed
area V4, or studied
humans who lacked area V4.
And he found that they had
difficulties in telling colors.
Well, that was nice.
But the problem was, and this
is a good lesson for all of us,
that the only
thing he tested was
for color, because that
was his hypothesis.
Had he tested for a
multitude of other functions,
he would have found
that area V4 has
much more significant
deficits when
it's removed for many
other visual functions
than for color.
So again, we'll talk about
that input with more detail
later on when we talk about
very specific processing
of digital attributes.
Now then the next areas
I want to deal with,
the last areas we
are going to discuss,
are going to be
areas MT and MST.
MT stands for Middle
Temporal area.
And MST stands for Middle
Superior Temporal area.
And again, to look at the
brain, what you can see here
is a superior temporal sulcus.
And if you went into it, it's
about 13 millimeters deep.
On the posterior
side, we have area MT.
And on the interior part
of it we have area MST.
Now, this is a remarkable area.
An incredible amount of
work had been done on it.
And the major discovery
that had been made
is that the cells in MT and
MST respond predominantly
to direction.
Virtually, all the cells
are direction specific.
And also, this is in part
believed to be due to the fact
that this area gets half their
input from the parasol system.
So to look at this
in more detail,
here is a receptive field,
quite large and empty.
And if you move a bar of light
across in this direction,
you get a huge response.
This is the cumulative
response histogram.
But if you move it in
the opposite direction,
you won't actually
get an inhibition.
Tremendous direction
specificity.
And you get the same in MST,
but there the receptive fields
are just gigantic.
But again, direction
specificity is just as specific
as it is in MT.
So these two areas
play a central role
in motion analysis, as we shall
see in more detail later on.
All right.
So now, if you look at the
spatial layout of this,
what you do is you can move
an electrode into the area.
And so you move it across
the represented area
by going into the sulcus.
And what you can see here is
it's a systematic progression
of directions as you
move the electrodes.
Here the distance is
expressed in micrometers.
OK?
Now, if you map that out you
can create a layout of the area,
area MT.
And what you can see is
there's a systematic kilometer
arrangement, or different
direction specificities.
So this is a general
principle, by the way,
of the way the
cortex is organized.
It first actually was
discovered by Mountcastle
in the somatosensory system.
OK?
Showing that there's a
kilometer arrangement there,
and then subsequently it
was shown that this is also
true for many other areas,
including vision and audition.
All right.
So now, the last thing I
want to mention very briefly,
we'll get back to it, is
so-called inferotemporal
cortex.
And here once again, we have
a map of the monkey cortex.
And this down here is
a temporal area here.
And this is where the
inferotemporal cortex resides.
And this has been
studied extensively
by people like Charlie
Gross, and more recently
with imaging techniques by
people in the department here.
It was shown that
this area has a lot
to do with object
recognition, face recognition.
A very complex high level area.
OK.
So now, I want to summarize
what I have covered today.
First of all, the
contralateral visual hemifield
is laid out topographically
in V1 in each hemisphere.
You know that by now, cold.
Secondly, the major
transforms in V1
are orientation, direction,
spatial frequency, selectivity,
binocularity.
You have an ON/OFF
convergence, and you
have also in many
cells a convergence
of the midget and
parasol systems.
Then V1 is organized
in a modular fashion.
Another way to
put it is that you
have a kilometer
organization, and that we
talked about three models
that had been proposed.
One of them, the original
one by Hubel and Wiesel,
is the ice cube model.
Then we had the radio
model, and the swirl model.
And I pointed out to you that
the swirl model is not really
a model.
It's a fact.
That's how it's laid out.
OK.
And then I said also that there
are more than 30 visual areas
that make more than
300 interconnections.
Extrastriate areas
do not specialize
in any one single
function, contrary to what
had been very, very popular,
maybe even 10 or 15 years ago.
The receptive field's
size in neurons
increases greatly in
progressively higher
visual areas.
That is a very
highly solid fact.
Then, area MT is involved
in the analysis of motion.
And as we shall see
later on, it also
contributes to
perception of depth,
and to flickering stimuli.
Area V4 engages in many
aspects of visual analysis,
and neurons have
dynamic properties.
Attention and eye
movements modulate
the way those cells respond.
And then in inferotemporal
cortex, high level
visual analysis takes place that
includes object recognition,
and therefore also the
recognition of faces.
So that then summarizes
what I had to say.
And to conclude
in general, we can
say that the cells
in the cortex have
one very important increase
in their mode of functioning
compared to lower areas, in that
the cells are multifunctional.
So any one cell can
tell you information
already in V1 about
direction, as well as
orientation and
spatial frequency.
So if one cell can do many,
many different things then
that's a good thing, because
if each cell in the brain
specialized in
one thing, it used
to be the hypothesis that was
called your famous grandmother
cell.
That there was a
cell in the brain
that represented
your grandmother.
Now, if that were the case,
that individual cells were
future selective, you
would need a brain
as big as this room to
accommodate the ability to what
you can do that
you can do anyway.
So cells in the brain
are multifunctional.
They carry out many,
many different analyses,
just like when computers do
complex mathematical analyses.
And because of that
it's very difficult,
of course, especially when you
study with high visual areas,
to learn just how
these cells function,
because to understand that
you would need to record
at the same time from virtually
all the cells in an area
to see what each of them does,
from which you can derive what
the actual analysis is.
So indeed, we have a very
complex task ahead of us
in trying to understand how
this very complex interaction
among neurons eventually
results in your ability
to analyze various aspects
of the visual scene.
And that's true not
only for vision.
It's true for many other areas.
In vision it's
very, very complex,
because you have all these
incredible number of cells.
As I mentioned before, you
have more than a million
retinal ganglion
cells that project
from the one eye, from
each eye, into the brain.
And then this multiplies in
these higher visual areas.
Then you have millions and
millions, billions of cells
to perform all of
these analyses.
Now by contrast, when you
look at the auditory system,
and I'm not saying
this to belittle it,
I'm just saying it's probably
easier to understand it,
because in the auditory
system the fibers that
project from the cochlear
nucleus amount to about 30,000
in each cochlear to the
central nervous system.
So we're talking about
20, 30-fold higher level
of number of neurons involved
in the visual system.
And that's of course
because vision for us
is just a very, very
important attribute,
perhaps more so than
many other attributes
that we have in
the nervous system.
OK.
So that's what I
have to cover today.
And then next time, you're
going to sort of move back.
We're going to talk about
the on and off channels
to try to understand why
on earth did they evolve.
OK?